or on va passer maintenant oc mehdorn
l'animatrice préférée des
les nominés
dans la catégorie award de l'animatrice
préférée des français les nommés sont
léa salamé pour son lapsus coquin il a
raison de sites arditi et bouygues sont
les avait la semaine dernière on les
salue et qu'est-ce que j'ai pas vu que
vous avez juillet juillet free
faustine bollaert des six invités aux
anecdotes toujours surprenante c'est fou
ce premier amour non mais attendez on
peut pas qu'est ce qu'on a comme
information aujourd'hui sur gérard blasé
son nom de famille de sa qu'il était du
nord
gérard comment la [ __ ] l abbaye de thé
sophie davant pour ses expressions de
djeuns
voilà des boîtes trop de la balle
et un bolide de malherbe à qui il ne
faut surtout pas dire de se calmer et la
présentation elle est très rapide et un
peu populiste moi et c'est nathalie
essayer de démontrer l'inversé pas à
calmer vos chiffres mais calmez vous
madame ça va bien se passer aujourd'hui
une baisse je trouve non sens ça va bien
se passer il y avait bien se passer mais
je
vous demande pardon comme ça va bien
c'est madame vous allez voir
alors jean pascal apolline apolline ah
non moi faustine bollaert justin voilà
ces raisons parce que parce que je
trouve qu'elle a une belle carrière est
une belle réussite c'est une animatrice
que j'aime beaucoup et je trouve que je
sais pas allez allez allez soi même il
erre aller moi c'est quelqu'un que
j'aime beaucoup donc je sais le moment
que je préfère
c'est ce qu'assurait léa salamé parce
que on peut dire ce qu'on veut ça a été
un numéro un cette année elle était sur
tous les fronts elle était à la radio
elle était chez ruquier lcd battre elle
sait faire des interviews politiques
elle a fait l'entre-deux tours c'est la
journaliste qui compte en ce moment là
numéro un stand sans débat possible et
je te voyais un débat dit
donc vous n'êtes pas d'appétit non moi
je suis comme je suis comme jean pascal
faustine bollaert déjà parce que je la
connais traversy et en plus se faire une
émission de confessionnelles tous les
après midi comme tous ses partenaires
sony estime à présent on va dire et de
choyer deux se disent est en tout cas
c'est très compliqué à faire et judy
elle le fait toujours avec
l'enthousiasmé l empathie avec les gens
elle m'a invité dans son émission et
c'est vrai qu'elle est plutôt agréable
on va avoir un extrait dans la longueur
dans la longueur et construire votre vie
mais vous avez quand même eu un peu
toujours l'ombre de gérard et c'est fou
ce premier amour non mais attendez on
peut pas qu'est ce qu'on a comme
information aujourd'hui sur gérard vous
avez son nom de famille mais c'est son
nom de famille je pensais qu'il était du
nord pierrard comment alors c'est un nom
qui va faire rigoler parce que c'est pas
trés non je respectais pas un nom très
flatteur mais surtout pour un mini de
faim surtout quand il était à l'armée
c'est bien qu'avoir un prénom atypique
parce que ça peut aider des gens
l'habite l abbaye de thé
[Rires]
mais c'est un effet d'annoncé pour ça
donc j'avais prévenu avant 1
elle est très agréable et pleine de
bienveillance et la vodka rebelles
padanie venons oui non mais deux mondes
c est aller se
confesser mais en revanche dans des
exercices de vrai journalisme c'est à
dire pour aller chercher une interview
non mais on demande à ces animaux à
l'origine l'animatrice la plus agréable
à est-ce que c'est ça le débat mais
avait on va passer monsieur pernikoff
qui a eu la chance d'avoir des
animatrices ah non je trouve sa
direction je trouve effectivement que
que faustine excellent dans son job
c'est pas un job très facile quand même
de faire des lignes comme ça
testimoniale est choquée lors ici plutôt
très bien et qu'elle a elle commence à
voir une jolie carrière voilà c'est vrai
que fossiles voilà c'est assez laid sur
la durée il quand elle a commencé de son
émission testimoniale en 2018 rappelez
vous c'était 400 mille téléspectateurs
elle monte elle fait des pointes à un
million deux elles réelles perdurent
comme ça dans cette es nié avec un
direct le vendredi très bien mais pour
moi c'est le cas aussi à véritablement
percer c'est léa salamé a quand même
récupéré le samedi soir de ruquier après
17 ans de bons et loyaux services
elle est sur la matinale la plus écoutée
à la radio elle a certes elle abandonne
l'année prochaine l'émission politique
d'ailleurs caroline roux est sur les
rangs pour passer et on verra ce que ça
donne sur la durée en tout cas c'est
quelqu'un de puissant alors moi je vais
redoubler de revoir quand même parce que
j'adore c'est appeler
à l'est pas vraiment les matrices aux
journalistes mais
c'est vrai que darmanin il aurait mieux
fait de se taire parce qu'elle la halle
à la fin cas c est ce que vous ne vous
êtes pas réveillé un peu tard sur ces
questions de sécurité j'en veux pour
preuve les chiffres qui viennent de
votre propre ministère les hausses de la
violence des atteintes aux personnes
homicide en hausse coups et blessures
volontaires en très nette hausse gérer
votre logo je pensais qu'on était sur
ses news mais en fait on est bien sur
des faits je vois pas le rapport ne dit
pas non plus et ce soit avec toi mais
parce que vous ne dites pas mais jma n'a
pas la même question blessés par les
matins l'occurrence opéra présentation
elle est très rapide et un peu populiste
moi et c'est la division essayer de
démontrer l'inversé ça a calmé vos
chiffres mais calmez vous madame ça va
bien se passer aujourd'hui une baisse de
30% servian ce passé il y avait bien se
passer
je vous demande pardon comme ça c'est
madame vous allez voir
sans il ya 30% de baisse sur les bien
moi j'en ai marre des discours
populistes
j'adore j'adore à plat mais elle est
très saine frac misogyne madame ça va
bien se passer ça veut dire quoi comme
ça il aurait fait près ces capsules
aurait dit
qu'il aurait fait ça fasse un film suit
l'arrivée toute confiance de orge
apolline de malheur c'est la révélation
de l'année les orléans dû parler que
d'elle elle a été exceptionnelle elle se
laisse pas faire c'est une femme de
poigne llc fait elle s'exprime très bien
et en plus elle est très gentil moi de
ma reçues il a été adorable vraiment mal
et on va le donner à affoler me ouais
[Applaudissements]